hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are starting off with
a very nice game a host a roll
Capablanca versus also Bernstein from
the 1911 san sebastian tournament but
before we get into that for those of you
who are just joining us we've covered
some of the stories from Capablanca is
used then we went his match against one
course oh the national champion of Cuba
then we also talked a little bit about
capablanca then we switched over to 1909
match against Frank James Marshall which
was basically his ticket to this
tournament even though he did not
officially get an invitation because to
get analyzation into this san sebastian
tournament which was in those days
considered to be the strongest
tournament ever held I know you will
hear that a lot but every next
tournament is basically the strongest
tournament ever held but this really was
and it featured such amazing players I
did I do have my sticky notes here like
a Kiba Rubenstein who was already a very
young but a very strong player a few
years from now I believe - you're one
year from now he will challenge Lasker
to a World Chess Championship match I
even though the match will never happen
dr. will and me Milind Vidmar then we
have Frank James Marshall who obviously
not only decided to play but it was
actually him who endorsed cover blanca
and convinced the organizer that
Capablanca should play for beating
marshall in such imagine because even
though Capablanca was such a strong
player in europe no one really knew all
that much about jose role as i know the
British chess magazine only published
two games from the match or or maybe two
or three games in the match against
Marshall and ok they saw a couple of
nice games but you know that that's not
much the you know created an opinion of
a player then we have a zebra tarush
cars later in 1910
car selector challenged in Alaska for
the title and it was a it was really a
thriller first four draws then car
collector won a game and he was leading
the match then again four draws followed
and collector only needed a draw to
the World Chess Championship title from
Lasker and then no one can explain this
a couple Bunco at that time that
selector was playing a match against
Lasker capablanca was a chief editor of
his own chess magazine in in Hana and he
he annotated games some very nice games
but also he annotated all of the games
from this match and he said that he
couldn't understand how slicer only
needed a draw and then selector started
to play the most attacking game of the
match and then he lost it
Lasker won that game the match ended in
a draw but Lasker kept his a World Chess
Championship title and capablanca says
that perhaps selector only he didn't
like his win in game 5 and then he
didn't want to win the match over a
fluke as he put it but ok I mean
definitely a strong player then we have
our own names of which everyone knows
names of which we have awesome awesome
bird sting Capablanca opponent in this
game rudolf gilman the legendary
attacker richard Aikman i guess i
Marazzi
Davian auskey almost burned all the read
auras and pulse all in a lung heart and
couple Blancas expectation prior to this
game were he said that he wouldn't mind
finishing let's say fourth in this
tournament behind behind the gaza
Marazzi Akiba Rubenstein and Karsh
laughter as he he considered him very
dangerous opponents and also before
starting the start of this tournament
Leon Paredes he was the president of the
Havana chess club sent an invitation to
Lasker to play a match against Aqaba
Blanca in few in Cuba Havana he said
that they should play a you know first
the 10 wins a draws down count and
Alaska replied that to those terms were
simply unacceptable that get this he
said that in today's day and age where
so many draws happened that that match
could last half a year or even more and
especially in that climate he could not
play more than a few games so last card
even in those days in 1910 he was he
thought there were too many draws in the
chess world I wonder what he'd think of
it you know in in modern chess our game
again
back to this tournament like we said to
get invited to this tournament the 1911
thoughts about sin tournament you had to
either win some very strong tournament
where were chess masters played or you
had to win I don't know a few second
places or even more third places or even
even more fourth places and you know as
far everyone was concerned couple Blanca
only won his match against Marshall so
really I think it was Marshalls doing
that couple blonde even got invited here
and Ossie Bernstein is one of our one of
the few that really protested to the
chief arbiter of having capablanca in
this tournament and capablanca says that
he was very happy that he was faced
against Bernstein in round one there is
a legend of Austin Bernstein I even made
a video on it once that he was taken
prisoner in a war and that well the the
general that was recommending the
opposite army said are you was Bernstein
the the chess master he said that he was
and then the generals asked him that if
he wins a match if he wins a game
against him that he would spare his life
and the legend goes that Bernstein did
win that game and well he survived and
the here he is but although I don't know
if that's a true story there aren't any
and there isn't any proof of this I
would really be interested in seeing
such a game if it's true but okay that's
enough for now but we're going to talk
about everything a bit more getting back
to this game so capablanca said he was
very happy that he was paired with
Bernstein in round one so he can prove
himself against the man who already
protested the you know of his
participation in this tournament and I
think you will enjoy this part very much
in the two years after the match with
Marshall in 1909
capablanca actually did study some games
of the Masters so we could say that he
knew some opening theory how much well
it's hard to say but okay couple Blanca
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and bush
to be 5 the rule opus nice to have six
couple Blanca castle said we have Bishop
to e7 and not nice to see three so we
have the Berlin defence d6 we have
Bishop captures on c6 b captures on c6
and now d4 capablanca are very often
captured the knight on c6 he gave up his
light square bishop and went for this d4
line he captures Knight captures and
Bishop to d7 protecting the c6 pawn and
Bishop to g5 so here you have a cap of
Lanka has a very nice developments very
nice natural development black has a
semi-open B file to use for his rook and
black has some very strong central
control so all in all it's a trade off
couple of luck I didn't really gain
anything in the opening it's playable
for both both sides we have castles by
Bernstein and now comes Luke to e1 and
ok
h6 Capablanca mentions in his book my
chest career that this has all been
played before so he does know some
opening theory Bishop to h4 and not nice
to h7 offering a trade of bishops and
then black can decide whether he wants
to go f5 in the future whether this
night will go back to f6 water to g5 or
the queen will use this diagonal for
herself
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Queen to d3 preparing to bring the other
broke into the game and also activating
the Queen rook 8 b8 of course you want
to use this very nice semi-open B file
b3 defending the b-pawn and now comes
Knight to g5 here Capablanca says that
this is a new move that this move was
not played in the games of the Masters
that he studied mostly they use this
diagonal for the Queen but here we have
Knight to g5 and here kappa blanka now
has to really start thinking as he
hasn't encountered this move before and
it's interesting
cabo blanco played rook a to d1 but if
you if you put the disposition into an
engine the engine will give you a couple
of suggestions the top two suggestions
will be rook a to D 1 which Papa Blanca
played the other one the lesser choice
will be F 4 and after the game
taraji recommend that a couple on cadet
perhaps f4 would have been a better move
here but you know the engine the engine
likes both moves so it's interesting
that these two legends you know
discussed the two favorite engine whines
but Capablanca mentions that okay if f4
then denied the ff4 denied retreats
sorry to East six which is where the
knight actually wants to go so he
thought why why help it but okay rook ad
one activating the last rook and now
queen bee five preventing f4 Queen to e3
now preparing f4 and now comes nice to
e6 getting the knight out of this attack
and also wanting to change this very
strong knight on d4 Knight c2e2 now
defending the knight here so if Knight
captures the the other night comes to d4
and you always want to keep this option
open for going Knight to f5 and here all
Bernstein had a choice you could simply
trade everything Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures Knight captures
and then c5 you kick away the night
night at five and after rook f8 f3 and
it would be a pretty pretty equal ish
position where okay black does have a
bishop but White's knight on f5 is
extremely strong you could either kick
it away by weakening your position not
yet as the H pawn would become weak but
perhaps in the future or you could give
up the bishop immediately and then we
would have an equal and game but here
Bernstein wants to go for something more
he plays Queen to a5 going for the weak
pawn and a2 and Capablanca says that
this is asking asking for too much he
goes Knight to f5 and here kappa blanka
has a very nice trick in mind it's not
not really a trick but an idea if black
actually captures the pawn then queen c3
comes with the threat of capturing the
Queen with rook to a1 but also it
pressures the g7 point the knight and
Queen are both attacking it and let's
say if you try it run away with the
Queen Queen a3 then comes Knight f4
you cannot capture the knight of course
due to the threat of checkmate like we
already mentioned here we would have to
go Queen c5 offer up trade of Queens but
after Queen
three again you're threatening you're
threatening Knight captures on e6
followed by Queen captures on g7
checkmate and after black prevents this
Queen at five you guard the GCM and pawn
you would at least lose a pawn with
Knight captures on h6 checked King moves
and now comes Knight captures Bishop
captures and then after the Queen's are
traded off knight retreats you would
have this position where couple where
the material is equal but couple Blancas
pawn structure is much better and he
will have a better game so Bernstein
doesn't like this he goes night to c5
and okay we have night e to d4 again a
queen g3 now isn't really doing anything
black and simply capture the night after
pawn captures go 94 attacks the queen
and after the Queen moves you can choose
whether you want to play d5 where you
want to protect it with the rook I would
want to go back night if six but black
would have a very comfortable game so
after Knight c5 we have a knight
eat it before threatening a lot of very
interesting ideas for example you still
can capture here because of rook to e1
and after Queen moves rook b1 not wins
the Queen on the other hand after Knight
84 if you try something like rook to be
four there is also this trick of Knight
chapters on c6 attacking both the Queen
and the rook so after you've captured in
97 check King has to move and now you
play Knight captures and c6 winning the
bishop and also now you're gonna grab
the exchange here and the white is
completely winning now so after this
night 84 we have kinked h7 by Bernstein
avoiding any checks on e7 white might
have in mind
and here Capablanca plays June 4 now if
this Knight is captured then even aji
captures on f5 will be an idea I wife
can always move the Queen double rooks
and G file will be a very nice attacking
formation so we have a look B to e 8 now
pressuring this pawn and now comes f3
strengthening the center we have Knights
to e6 but now comes Knight to e2 cover
Blanc avoids the trade of knights and
here black has a couple of options but
here he decided to actually capture the
pawn and while this is not a mistake in
itself
capablanca says that the position
becomes very difficult to play for black
perhaps capturing in the pond was not
the the greatest of ideas here but okay
if Bernstein wanted to play for a draw
he he could have done it earlier in the
game so he wants to beat Capablanca and
prove that Capablanca is unworthy of
participating in this tournament Knight
eat the g3 capablanca is preparing nice
to h5 sorry there's something wrong with
the arrows this game so sorry if I miss
a few of them he's preparing Knights to
h5 and here sorry I almost said
Schleifer Bernstein captures even the c2
pawn and now Capablanca says that this
is just giving white too much of course
now that Bernstein grabbed two pawns if
he can defend he will of course have a
winning position but that's only if he
can defend the banca first place
not tonight h5 but first rook to see one
kicks the Queen away we have Quinta b2
and now it's very important to kick the
Queen off of this diagonal and this is
how Capablanca does it first knife to h7
and okay we have worked to h8 trying to
bring the rook into the defense and hide
the King away via King to g8 and now
comes a rook to e2 again attacking the
Queen forcing her to move from this
diagonal Bernstein still keeps the Queen
on this diagonal you have to keep an end
on the g7 pawn and now of course comes
f4 and now the Queen finally has to move
it's best for blacks to just give up the
night here Knight captures on f4 and
then try to play this game on but here
it's simply it's simply not possible
here after f4 Queen to b5 was played and
now comes Knight F captures on g7 and
this is a now a very difficult position
to play for black Capablanca said that
he started this idea on move 21 but he
couldn't really create create it if
Bernstein didn't to go for for a win by
grabbing all the points on the Queen
side but he said it was simply not
possible and here Bernstein did not
capture the knight Bernstein played
night to c5 but
Blanka says this is a week couple Marco
was what Capablanca was hoping for well
perhaps not hoping for but going for was
after night captures Knight f6 check the
King has to go to g6 as the g8 square is
covered Knight captures and now Pokemon
conventions that f5 would be strongest
for black here you have to create some
squares for your king after G captures
an f5 King f7 rook to g2 Rob joins the
attack and here it would be very
difficult to repel this Queen d4 c3
could the Queen can also join the attack
it would be it would be just an
excellent position for white and this is
what capablanca was going for but after
night after g7 nice to see if I was
played and here our cup of lanka will
simply grab the rook and he will be out
of the exchange in a much better
position and couple monka says if
Burstein already didn't want to accept
my knight and go for that variation that
he should have just resigned rather than
playing this weak position but ok night
cap from sunny 8 we have Bishop captures
and now Queen to c3 kappa blanka
threatens checkmate here we have f6 and
as much you can do to prevent it
or Ruby g8 but then you get Knight f6
and then you lose the rook as well so f6
was played Knight captures on f6 check
and now King to g6 we have nice to h5
now threatening Queen g7 checkmate so
rock now has to go to g8 with rook to g8
and now f5 check now we have King to g15
to h7 again you have this check that
loses the rook so King to g5 was played
and here you have a few ways to go about
this position so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the move or
the winning line it's actually a mate in
7/4 capablanca so you know now pause the
video and give it your give it your all
I will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent major in seven and for those
of you who just want to enjoyed show
Capablanca played Queen to e3 but if you
played h4 this is all
so a force checkmate so congratulations
to everyone who found this as well after
King captor sunji for Lu Zhi to check
King captors an h4 and now an IG 7
prepares queen g3 checkmate
so after Luke captures and g7 Queen
captures and now again there is no
defense against Queen G for checkmate
and black can just waste a couple of
moves by sacrificing pieces but it's
first chance white gates it will be
checkmate
but capablanca played Queen to e3 check
and then it was in this position that
awesome Bernstein resigned the game
after King age 4 you would get either
Queen g3 check King g5 and h4 checkmate
or after this Queen e3 yeah if you go
something like King after sin g4 then
you get a similar idea Knight f6 check
King to h4 you get Knight captures and
g8 now the Queen is free to roam the G
file and a frecuency after Sun b3 Queen
a4 check King h3 Queen captures on h6
check King g4 Queen Knight to f6 check
King moves to f3 and now you get rope to
F 2 and this will be checkmate
but Bernstein didn't allow this after
Queen e3 he simply resigned and
Capablanca started this strongest
tournament in his life the tournament
that was considered to be the strongest
tournament ever held with a victory
against Aussie Bernstein a chess master
who also considered one of the strongest
in the world who will oppose the
Capablanca even being there so Polanco
was very happy not only that he was
paired to play against him but also that
he won this beautiful game which was not
only a victory for him but also it was
awarded the brilliant surprise for this
tournament so even that went in his
favor but the other strong players were
still weren't convinced that couple
Blanca had the right to play in this
tournament even though he won this very
nice game but we are going to talk about
that in some other videos in this san
sebastian tournament so yeah i mean we
just started this tournament so this is
a video is a bit longer the other the
others will be a bit shorter as you know
there will not be so much story up front
but to I will always try to include as
much as possible
sir now I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you are enjoying the Capablanca
saga so far I would like to thank
Alfredo Peguero Rivera AJ baking in
power seaman soccer and Anthony wisdom
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
video see are thankful for watching and
I will see you soon with some more
interesting videos from the Capablanca
saga and and well whatever we get we can
get our hands on thank you all and I'll
see you soon